racontez-nous d'abord philippe
l'histoire après on va voir ce qu'ils en
ont pensé et dit sa vérité n'est pas
toujours oui oui philippon soir bonsoir
c'est richard merci de m'accueillir
l'histoire le pitch c'est un peu
compliqué de sur cette classement fait
l'idée c'est que ces deux garçons deux
copains qui ont des ambitions
qui sont les leurs serres qui ils ont
ouvert un carrot cake qui n'avait pas
marché ils rêvent d'en ouvrir un
deuxième estelle lefébure qui joue mon
épouse dans la pièce aimerait bien les
jeux prennent un vrai travail et que je
me mettre à devenir adulte et je suis
évidemment pas très encouragé par mon
copain qui est à peu près le même que
moi en fait j'aime beaucoup de cette
pièce parce que ces deux personnages à
mon sens d'être gentil voilà c'est noël
gentil qui qui qui ont dont l'ambition
n'est pas la réussite l'ambition c'est
d'être heureux voilà
[Rires]
vous avez beaucoup d'ambition
mais non c'est évidemment très drôle
très attachant et le truc génial c'est
effectivement je comprends que vous ayez
envie de mettre en scène matt pokora
parce que vous êtes contre emploi entier
autant dire que normalement vous avez un
corps vous êtes une rock-star vous êtes
l'animal vous dansez bien vous bougez
bien et dans cette quête vous êtes tout
étriqué vous n'avez pas de corps vous
bougez pas il ya un vrai travail là
dessus et qui est juste je trouve moi
génial et régions
c'est pas facile d'ailleurs justement
est ce que je disais tu te renseignes
c'est ça que j'ai découvert de jouer
d'interpréter un rôle pendant 1h20
non-stop comme ça c'est très très
éprouvant parce qu'en fait il ya toute
la gestuelle en fait il faut oublier qui
on est et vraiment se concentrer sur ce
personnage quand quand j'ai tourné le
téléfilm par exemple il ya deux ans
robin cdsn ça dure 30 secondes une
minute deux minutes donc cesser c'est
pas éprouvant psychologiquement et là en
fait c'est une heure vingt où on est
vraiment dans la peau de quelqu'un
d'autre ou toute la gestuelle doit
rester la même quand on s'assoit on doit
penser comme l'autre personne comment
elle s'assit ray etc quand on regarde
dans le vide faut que ce soit le regard
de l'autre personne fin c'est très
intéressant en tout cas comme
ça pas été très compliqué parce qu'il a
en renfort en fait il est il il a
vraiment ça il a le sens de la scène ce
jour là c'est plus à prouver il a le
sens du rythme et les c'est hyper
important je sais qu'il est de bon ton
de dire que la comédie est un art facile
mais c'est à mon avis ce qui a pu déjà
dit 'tiens
ses montées non mais si oui
c'est ça mine
écrit beau quand même
ya des très belles filles j'étais au
marché aux corps
et aux figues mais j'adore
les stands à penser ben moi j'ai
beaucoup aimé et puis il faut quand même
reconnaître un sacré performance pour
matt s'est pas du tout satisfait
qu'à tous les jeux 10 moi j'ai aimé on
s'est beaucoup amusé et on a beaucoup
rigolé c'est vrai ce qui a des attaches
ans et qui sont archi bienveillant c'est
un soleil aussi elle est magnifique elle
arrive elle illuminait les magnifiques
essais et tous les deux ils sont
tellement sympathique parce qu'ils en
ont l'air un peu un peu pas de bonnet
mais deux mecs trop gentil comme sa
deuxième ligne on ne sait pas gai tia ça
ou ça c'est drôle c'est des conneries et
ça nous fait rire c'est extrêmement
sympathique moi j'ai beaucoup de plaisir
à voir la pièce parle et nous l'aimions
comme ça avait pas vu
les pièces que vous lisez nom
alors je vais vous dire le problème
qu'on a avec les les personnes comme
bernard que j'aime beaucoup dans
certains traités les scènes de la pièce
dans la pièce est très drôle et quand on
nous raconte
non je crée l'ambiance je raconte mes
et je relève c'est une sacrée
performance pour ma part ce que fut
philippe il est encore l'habitude mais
monter sur scène comme ça bon une rock
star ben c'est pas évident et
aux
frais de la princesse du fesman
non mais sans rire et benayoun sur quoi
tu veux te paye et hewitt c'est pourquoi
je vais te faire une formule 1
avant et après et gaby newey a dit non
mais moi j'ai absolument adoré et
surtout moi je suis une grande grande
grande grande fan de philippe au théâtre
parce que c'est vraiment un comédien
exceptionnel sud et qui a cette
bienveillance et le personnage est aussi
ça de ne pas écraser mater de le prendre
avec lui et de l'emmener avec lui dans
un endroit qui est cet endroit de la
bienveillance et 2 et de ces deux gars
de ces garçons de ses deux garçons qui
veulent pas être étriqué qui veulent
qu'ils veulent être des hirondelles qui
veulent voler qui va le grand
[Applaudissements]
il ya là
des gens font ça te plaît vraiment oui
benhaim non on se respecte on en reste
là oui c'est ma
soeur mais calme toi oui on te connais
tu as fait une carrière d'être assurée
toute la carrière
[Rires]
d'un dictionnaire joie montaigne asus
heures à la hauteur
bien
on a obtenu 37 ans comment on fait pour
y arriver autrement bah c'est vrai
d'ailleurs on a toujours latent fayçal
on l'a tous fait nous l'ait pas fait
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jamais jamais jamais a été l'inversé si
ce n'est et vient d'où ce cheveu sur la
langue à l'eau
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
documation balance
alors oui non mais voilà et est-ce qu'il
faut dire on a beaucoup parlé du rythme
de l'humour et de la pièce mais c'est
surtout moi la tendresse de cette pièce
cette pièce est tendre mais adrien
racaille il avait fait la beauté la
pièce avec l'homme
qui était beaucoup plus dans la drôlerie
et là on est vraiment dans la tendresse
de cure seront sur la tendresse et drôle
bien évidemment assez très agile bernard
gilles verdez énormément il n'aime rien
de tel avec qui déjà tout seul non
tu m'aurais du gîte avec cinq potes
on a tout donné on dit à des amis toi
[Rires]
dès que je croise quelqu'un mes proches
leur dit il faut qu'on retourne voir les
grandes ambitions parce que c'est vous
avez envoyé comme un porc
c'était samedi il à s'arrêter
enthousiasme beaucoup de jeunes on dit
que les jeunes vont potins seyamak
eliana dont philippe salle je ris peut
il est jeune le qu'il faut six
exactement public était là irrésistible
c'est drôle c'est un moment de grave et
même vos fous rires parce qu'il ya eu
beaucoup de sourires entre vous c'est
que vous n'êtes rien c'était génial et
c'est communicatif
franchement ces essais des dialogues
super porté par un texte incisif je vous
ai trouvé alors vous je sais mais mes
maths c'est une vraie révélation
honnêtement vous étiez fait pour le
théâtre je suis content que vous ayez
franchi ce cap et je vous suivre toute
votre carrière
mais super contente et la
différence avec moi là ça n'a rien à
voir voilà l'agent faire
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
de telles voix de miel mais bon c'est le
fig au miel toi
championnat